warum soll ich arbeiten gehen arbeiten
das für asoziale und wir arbeiten geht
ist selbst schuld also 200 herzlich
kommt einem die leute nehmen wir heute
wieder mit deutschlands zukunft
auseinandersetzen werden die zukünftigen
bundeskanzler die zukünftigen
dax-vorstände anwälte und ärzte behält
ihr in dieser folge wieder zu sehen
bekommen heute ihr wissen was es
bedeutet wird sie uns heute eine neue
folge von die strengsten eltern der welt
ich habe eine sehr knappe vier
ausgesucht kurze informant leute diese
die strengsten eltern der welt wir sind
bei mir in aller regel gelb das heißt
ich verdiene damit meistens keinen cent
aber wir euch diesen gefallen machen
heute wieder ein neues und wir haben
einen ein schmankerl leute schauen war
sinnvoll bereits nach kurzer zeit wie
vor arbeiten ist was für asoziale wie
wir ihn aus berlin
auch wir hier in aus bernau bei berlin
erwartet nicht viel vom leben
die schule abgebrochen party sich die
ich keinen bock auf direkt so viel
habt ihr das gerade eben gesehen ich
werde jetzt nicht noch mal zurückspulen
leute ich werde nicht nochmals
zurückholen was wir gerade eben schon
gesehen haben aber wie wien 17 scheint
sich gewisse qualitäten per buch
aneignen zu wollen okay wir gehen die
schule abgebrochen party sich die ich
keinen bock auf arbeit 17 jahre und noch
nichts geleistet aber von allen die
christ der klappe ich frage mich immer
was meinen die leute damit wenn sie
sagen party süchtig leute was bedeutet
party sich die ich eigentlich das lese
ich immer wieder dass leute über die
teenager schreiben ja diesen party
süchtig check check was hier abgeht
partys kann man nicht rauchen ok partys
kann man sich auch nicht kochen und in
den arm rheinbacher oder sonst was man
kann partys auch nicht durch die nase
zieht wissen was wir heute so eine
partie ist einfach eigentlich und
abstrakter begriff der von der
zusammenkunft von leuten in einem
gewissen setting bezeichnet so zu können
leute dann auch wüssten auch schule
werden oder nach
fortbildungsveranstaltung
ja ok kurz vor kurzem noch am rande
libyen kommt aus berlin der leute dürfen
an der stelle nicht vergessen mal ganz
unabhängig davon woher sie kommt per se
ist das schon mal eine schlechte idee
durch die stadt zu gehen und jeden
anzupöbeln mit wie siehst du denn aus zu
lappen weil sie die jungs sitzen da
einfach die chillen einfach snacken sich
naser herein snacken sich vielleicht war
ein so oft ganz entspannt mit gar kein
reden und dann kommt diese platte
darüber sagt kuchen arschloch ich lasse
mir zu einem visum also eins zu eins ich
nach dem abitur sich war eins zu eins so
safe der hauptsache hauptsache
vorarbeiten ja erstmal ein bisschen kann
man es nachvollziehen
aber was ist schon da gerade eben hat
die nach der neunten klasse hatten
achten klasse die schule abgebrochen ja
gut das ist wieder etwas anderes wenn
sie sage ich jetzt mal abitur in der
tasche hast hast gerade einen uni
abschluss gemacht aber sowas dann kann
es erst mal sagen you also jetzt bevor
die fackel jetzt hier richtig anbrennen
ist weich wird so der pause sich nach
dem schulabbruch erste pause zu nehmen
ist natürlich auch okay mutter yvonne
redet gegen eine wand
sie selbst musste schon sehr früh für
den familienunterhalt sorgen mit nur 19
jahren hat sie ihr töchterchen zur welt
gebracht na ja das ist natürlich auch
schwierig leute also ich weiß es nicht
ganz genau aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass gerade mütter die so
junge kinder bekommen
jetzt geht es für jede mutter aber viele
mütter sind da mit sicherheit
überfordert kann ich mir vorstellen wenn
ich mir überlege wo war ich mit 19 war
ich gerade so wie beim studium drin
ich war ziemlich unerfahren junger
mensch der wirklich keine ahnung vom
leben an und jetzt immer so dass wir
immer wieder denke sollte das nicht mal
einen ganzen zeug aber mit 19 ein kind
zu bekommen und das dann richtig zu
erziehen schwer
dementsprechend drehen glaube ich auch
kinder von sehr jungen müssen wenn er
mal durch wir werden ist nun fast
volljährig übernimmt dabei keinerlei
verantwortung
da haben wir es leute da haben wir es
eine es ist eine wie eine ware
philosophie eine wahre philosophin
lassen wir uns das kurz mal auf der
zunge zergehen
fragen wir uns mal was steckt eigentlich
dahinter denkt ihr wie viel zeit wir in
17 aus berlin sagt so was ohne sich
vorher gedanken gemacht zu haben
über die metaphysischen implikationen
ihre aussage ist auf jeden fall eine
stabile aussage heute kann man mal so
stehen lassen wie alle kennen das ekel
gefühl was in einem hoch kommt wenn man
morgens durch die stadt geht und man
sieht einen erfolgreichen
investmentbankern seinem sportwagen und
denkt sich was für sie alter direkt die
nächste bombe
ja wir arbeiten geht ist selbst schuld
wir schon mal hier ist bisher nämlich
vor die brust wird kann erst gesagt ihr
knüpft die mir mal vor so ja also an
alle da draußen noch arbeiten gehen
spinnt ihr spinnt ihr denn ihr seid
selbst schuld daran wenn ihr geld
verdient selbst schuld ist also auch
ihre mutter die täglich um halb vier zur
arbeit fährt
als dank ernte die supermarkt
abteilungsleiterin pöbelei dank wofür
wir haben schon ist erwischt sie ist
selbst schuld dass sie arbeiten geht sie
könnte ja auch einfach nicht arbeiten
gehen und geld würde einfach trotzdem
vom himmel fallen wie im schlaraffenland
land wir leben doch im schlaraffenland
in deutschland heute also mehr als das
ist eine sache sozusagen ja ich bin
selbst für mich selbst so faul so ich
will erst mal ich weiß ich sollte was
machen aber ich lebe ich erstmal zurück
in der sache ist zu sagen dass alle
anderen die arbeiten gehen und geld
verdienen und damit der familie ernähren
so ist es heute so ist es nämlich und
ganz ehrlich jetzt mal an alle eltern da
draußen in deutschland die mit zum miss
ankommen wie erziehung oder mithelfen im
haushalt ja an euch geht diese affen zu
machen ist ja gerade eltern deutsche die
die stelle könnte aber auch den eltern
zeigen liebe eltern in deutschland ja
wenn ihr jetzt sagt okay meine kinder
sollen im haushalt mithelfen wie sollen
verantwortung übernehmen habt ihr das
ganze mal durchdacht habt ihr mal
durchdacht das mit hilfen im haushalt
arbeit ist und dass arbeiter sozialist
wollt ihr dass eure kinder asozial
werden das ist aus dem klassik über die
strengsten eltern der welt immer so wie
bei hilft mir immer aus dem portemonnaie
verdeckt geklaut wird machen sich beide
strengsten eltern der welt einfach in
your face die mutter sitzt da ja sagt
gerade sohn eine fixe kein geld von mir
und die tochter nimmt sich vor ihren
augen ihrer handtasche und ist somit
wichtig nimmt sich das daraus zu er ja
also da sieht man schon die kippt die
drehen vollkommen frei also wer sich
sowas traut vor den eigenen eltern und
nicht fürchten muss dass er mit einem
nudelholz behinderten wird der hat nicht
nein also kinder schlagen dann bist du
dich mal die größten ängste sind
natürlich dass wir uns vorab rutscht
nach ganz unten gerutscht
das hat vielleicht irgendwann um angeht
so kann kann ich auch verstehen kann ich
noch verstehen
ich wollte gerade jetzt schon einen
dummen spruch bringen aber so nach dem
motto so dass sie irgendwann runter
rutscht ich mein so sind wir mal
objektiv leute wie wien ist auf der
rutsche okay sie ist auf der rutsche
drauf und er hat schon gute rutsch
geschwindigkeit also sie hat schon so
basierte vergleichen
sie hatten so die badehose oder die den
blick nicht so bisschen reingezogen ihr
wisst was ich meine so dass man besser
rutsch ja aber sie ist noch nicht ganz
unten
[Musik]
das ist nämlich leute wenn die eigene
mutter wieder mal so hängen geblieben
ist und nicht weiß was einem als kind
eigentlich zusteht nämlich die hälfte
ihres einkommens ja dann das mündet
mindestens die hälfte eigentlich noch
mehr aber sollen wir die hälfte von
ihrem nettoeinkommen steht am stand zu
als kind und wenn ich so wird es sind
das nicht realisiert dann kann man da
natürlich auch mal klauen
diese einstellung also ich will mich
auch gar nicht zu krass übertreiben
sollte ich bin auch und kind was schon
einiges im leben sicher bekommen hat und
auch viele privilegien bekommen die es
nicht immer ganz richtig eingeschätzt
hat und manchmal auch für selbstständig
angenommen hat aber das ist von gracia
in bernau erinnert sich mutter yvonne an
glücklichere zeiten mit ihrer tochter
die heute aber gute kritiken
mittlerweile auch so den aufbau von
diesen seiten und checken dass sie auch
immer genau gleich gemacht werden
am anfang ist immer so was so barm in
your face man sich zu denkbar oder frage
was geht da ab und dann kommt irgendwas
anderes und dann am ende immer so ein
bisschen die tränendrüse
also ich fällt mir zu machen das auf
euch bestimmt auch wenn das immer wieder
sehen jetzt kommt so die emotionale
phase und eigentlich ist auch immer das
gleiche sie schauen auch immer
kinderbilder an immer immer egal welche
folge ist wenn immer kinder bilder
angeschaut und dabei schon irgendwo
abgeschlossen
wenn sie jetzt gehen bruder weg frei
jo jo
das ist krass das ist wirklich ein
krasses statement das ist auch eines der
krassesten statements die im rahmen von
dieser sender überhaupt jemals gehört
habe heftig die meisten sind ja so ja
ich weiß nicht mehr weiter weiß ich
genau machen soll aber also die sagen so
ich bin mit der situation jetzt gerade
nicht nicht nicht zufrieden so ich will
da irgendwas dran ändern aber machen
gleichzeitig nicht so diese tür auch so
dass das eigene kind irgendwie geht oder
so sie ist ja wirklich schon so
innerlich distanziert deutet checkte was
ich meine
sie ist ja wirklich so sony kein bock
mehr auf die versuchte auch gar nicht
mal irgendwas zu machen
aber gut ich meinen sie ist bei die
strengsten eltern der welt was das
wiederum hilft im alt durchschnitt
kommen auch fragen aber schon krass
leute ja ich muss sagen in wie vielen
sehe ich persönlich eine kandidatin auf
das bundeskanzleramt wir müssen alle
bedenken angela merkel geht irgendwann
auch mal in ruhe stand da muss erst mal
nachfolgerin okay dann ist vielleicht
ein bisschen jung aber danach dann die
fähre danach der kommt dann das ist die
frage da würde ich kämpfen
da sehe ich will auf jeden fall gerade
ihr motto arbeiten ist unsere soziale
wird deutschland als volkswirtschaft
weiter voranbringt ganz wichtig jetzt
für euch leute wenn ihr nicht wollt dass
ihr durch eure eigene arbeit asozial
werdet dann natürlich und ein völlig
neues video ab und abonniert hier oben
einen kanal
ich bin der schule raus macht's gut